five years ago
lamed filmmaker Alejandro Gonzalez
Inarritu embarked on making a bold new
work to bring empathy and compassion for
the immigrants who cross our southern
border as they flee the poverty and
violence of their homelands knowing that
one of the most powerful things drama
can do is to have us walk in the
footsteps of others Alejandra wanted to
take this to a whole new level having
this literally walk in the footsteps of
these immigrants using the emerging
technology of virtual reality as the
centerpiece of a 3-tier multimedia
installation with the help of his
longtime colleague cinematographer
Emmanuel Lubezki of producer Mary parent
and visual effects house ILM and using
the Testaments of hundreds of immigrants
Alejandro has created an interactive
experience called Carinae lladhina flesh
and sand that puts us in the desert at
dawn walking barefoot with immigrants
risking their lives as they are hunted
by the u.s. Border Patrol the rectangle
of the screen has vanished and we are
surrounded by sirens lights assault
rifles the harsh orders of border patrol
officers the anguished screams and
weeping of the men women and children
around us we sit on metal benches as
captured immigrants do in the freezing
holding cells of detention centers later
we walk down a corridor lined with
actual pieces of the rusted border fence
where we see the portraits of the people
we have just been traveling with and
learned their heartbreaking stories my
fellow governor director Michael Mann
said that by putting us in the skin of
this experience seeing with the
immigrants eyes and feeling their
distress
with an intensity never done before
carne yah denna is to virtual reality
what Eisenstein's Battleship Potemkin
was to film carne denna is a true drama
urging us to not build walls of hatred
and fear but to build bridges of
compassion and understanding
[Applause]